It's often the case that MapReduce code is written in
Java. However, to make things a little easier for us,
we've actually written our mapper and reducer in Python instead.
And we can do that thanks to a feature called Hadoop
streaming, which allows you to write your code in pretty
much any language you'd like. So first of all, let's
double-check that we have our input data in HDFS. So,
if I Hadoop fs minus ls, then there's my input directory.
And if I look at that directory, then
yes, there's purchases.txt in there. And in my local
directory, I have mapper.py and reducer.py, that's the
code for the mapper and reducer, written in Python.
We'll look at the actual code in the
next lesson. Okay, to submit the job we have
to give this rather cumbersome command. We say hadoop
jar, a path to a jar, then I specify
the mapper, I specify the reducer, I need to say -file, for both the mapper and
the reducer code. I specify the input directory in HDFS and I specify the output
directory to which the reducers will write their
output data. And we're calling that joboutput. I
hit Enter and off we go. Hadoop's pretty verbose, as you can see. As the job
runs, you'll see a bunch of output which shows us how
far along the job is. It turns out that for this
job Hadoop will be running four mappers. And our virtual machine
here can only run two at a time. So the job is
going to take longer than it would on a larger cluster.
Actually, that's worth mentioning here. With the size of the data we
have for this example which is only 200 megs, realistically, we
could probably have solved this problem faster by just importing the data
into a relational database and querying it from there.
And that's often the case when we're developing and testing
code. Because the test data sets are pretty small, Hadoop
isn't necessarily the optimal tool for the job. But when
we're done testing and we need to process our full
production data, that's when Hadoop really comes into its own.
So, as you can see the job is now nearly
complete, and when the job has finished we'll get a
[UNKNOWN]
output. And we'll see that the last line tells
me that the output directory is called joboutput. Let's
take a look at what we've got in there.
Hadoop fs minus ls, shows me that yes I do
have a job output directory. And if we look
at the job output directory, you'll see that it
contains three things. It contains a file called _SUCCESS,
which just tells me that the job has successfully completed.
It contains a directory called _logs, which
contains some log information about what happened during
the job's run. And then, it contains a
file called part-00000. That file is the output
from the one reducer that we had for this job. Let's take a look at that by
saying hadoop fs minus cat part 00000, and we'll pipe that to less on
our local machine. That's the contents of that file,
which is the output from our reducer. It's the
sum total sales broken down by store exactly as
we want it. Incidentally, if you want to retrieve data
from HFDS and put it onto your local disk,
you can do that with Hadoop fs minus get.
Hadoop fs minus get is the opposite of Hadoop
fs minus put. It just pulls data from HDFS and
puts it on the local disk. So as you can see, now I have
my local file.txt on my local disk And I can manipulate that however I'd like.